[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales del
programa de France 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas los ojos del
mundo están puestos en Qatar sede del
evento deportivo más importante del
planeta el mundial de fútbol es la
fiesta que todos esperaron pacientemente
durante cuatro años sin embargo esta
cita mundialista ha estado marcada por
la controversia sobre todo por las
denuncias de violaciones a los derechos
humanos y la explotación a la que fueron
sometidos los trabajadores muchos de
ellos inmigrantes que ayudaron en la
construcción de la infraestructura
deportiva que el país tuvo que levantar
prácticamente de la nada un equipo de
Francia 24 hizo la siguiente radiografía
de la situación de esta población
migrante en Qatar informe de Itan allí
cientos de trabajadores inmigrantes en
las calles de doja celebrando el mundial
algunos llevan más de 10 años levantando
los escenarios donde se jugará Qatar
2022 la situación de los trabajadores
inmigrantes en el emirato rico en
petróleo ha sido el centro de la
polémica de esta copa del mundo los
petrodólares de Qatar han atraído humano
de obra de Asia y África los migrantes
representan ahora más del 80% de la
población del país estos trabajadores
que han construido los estadios y otras
infraestructuras se alojan en remotas e
insalubres ciudades dormitorio Fran 24
se reunió con varios de ellos que
afirmaron no haber recibido su salario
en meses
todos los días nos prometen que nos van
a dar el sueldo pero no nos lo dans la
empresa nos ha quitado todos los
pasaportes que debemos hacer aquí esto
es esclavitud esto es una especie de
prisión están abusando de los Derechos
Humanos
largas jornadas de trabajo Un calor
sofocante a menudo sin límite de tiempo
y por salarios irrisorios condiciones
denunciadas por varias ong
Qatar aplicó algunas reformas a partir
de 2018 pero tres años después su Garden
reveló que 6.500 trabajadores
extranjeros han muerto desde la
adjudicación del mundial
cifras que dujah han negado cuando
rotundidad mundo
este que se nos concedió la Copa del
Mundo catarsia enfrentado a una campaña
de críticas sin precedentes como ningún
otro país
muchos se preguntan por las verdaderas
motivaciones de estos ataques
y algunas federaciones nacionales de
fútbol han tenido que se cree un fondo
para compensar a las familias de los
trabajadores que han muerto durante las
obras del mundial pero
Qatar se opone firmemente
otro encuentro que acaparó las miradas
del mundo fue la co-27 la Cumbre
climática de la ONU que se celebró en
Egipto se selló con un acuerdo histórico
para la compensación de países
vulnerables por las pérdidas y daños
generadas por el calentamiento global
sin embargo dejó mucho que desear cuando
detectar una reducción de combustibles
fósiles se trata los peligros del
calentamiento global son muchos y uno de
ellos es el aumento considerable en el
nivel del mar en los próximos años y uno
de los países más vulnerables a ese
fenómeno es Dinamarca Por lo cual este
país europeo se ha embarcado en un
proyecto tan titánico como polémico para
intentar proteger sus costas informe de
anmaye Willy malea y Nick spicer
en Dinamarca lo llaman el proyecto del
siglo un archipiélago artificial surgirá
aquí en el estrecho de orezunt frente a
copenhague en el 2070 el objetivo evitar
que la subida de las aguas sumerja la
capital con una altitud media de solo 34
metros sobre el nivel del mar Dinamarca
es uno de los países más bajos del mundo
aquí está la presa y luego esta parte de
aquí será la parte de protección los
responsables del proyecto afirman que la
Península de linant funcionará como una
parte remota que protegerá la capital
donde vive una quinta parte de la
población del país
La Isla está al nivel del mar más 4
metros y en la parte oriental donde se
encuentra el Mar habrá un paisaje de
hasta 6 metros para protegerse de las
olas
desde el siglo 17 copenhague ha crecido
sobre el agua Gracias a las Islas
artificiales esta península que se
extiende a lo largo de 3 kilómetros
cuadrados ofrece 35.000 viviendas pero
justo cuando comienza la primera fase de
construcción del inet hall ya los
ecologistas dan la voz de alarma
el lugar donde estamos navegando tiene
la misma biodiversidad que la gran
Barrera de coral de Australia es la gran
Barrera de coral de Europa y lo que
estamos haciendo es destruirlo
ahora ya tenemos esta sustancia venenosa
corriendo de nuestro Puerto
los habitantes de la ciudad ya están
preocupados según una encuesta solo el
3% de ellos aprueba el proyecto que
costará los contribuyentes unos 2.500
millones de euros pase lo que pase
copenhague necesita protección con o sin
este proyecto
[Música]
ya sea con diques o con la isla de
lincoln y también habrá algún tipo de
compuerta similares por ejemplo a lo que
han hecho en Venecia
el año que viene empezarán a construir
los contornos de la Península de línea
se necesitarán más de 100 metros cúbicos
de tierra para que salga del estrecho de
orson
en Francia la iglesia vuelve a estar
sumida en un escándalo por abusos
sexuales esta vez el cardenal Jon
piafrica admitió haber abusado de una
niña de 14 años 35 años atrás una
revelación que contribuye al aumento de
la impopularidad de la Iglesia Católica
que suma al menos 200.000 Víctimas de
abusos sexuales en el país desde los
años 50 informe de
los obispos se reúnen en Lourdes al
suroeste de Francia para hacer frente a
un nuevo escándalo de acoso sexual en el
centro de la última revelación el
cardenal Jean Pierre ricard uno de los
más altos pero helados de la Iglesia
Católica francesa de admitió sus abusos
en una declaración escrita el lunes
hace 35 años cuando era sacerdote me
comporté de forma reprobable con una
niña de 14 años mi comportamiento causó
inevitablemente consecuencias graves y
duraderas en esta persona
la confesión del cardenal se produce
apenas un mes después de otro caso de
abuso sexuales que sacudió a la iglesia
católica el exobismo del critea Michelle
Santiago se retiró el año pasado tras
ser acusado de hacer desnudar a chicos
jóvenes por cada pecado confesado una
investigación independiente realizada en
2021 estimó más de 200.000 víctimas de
abusos por parte del clero en Francia
desde los años 50
el hecho de la celebración de esta rueda
de prensa sobre la revelación relativa
al cardenal ricard toda esta
evidentemente relacionado hay una mayor
concienciación en la iglesia
católicas franceses han sido acusados de
violencia sexual o de no denunciar en
los casos de abuso y se enfrentan a un
juicio o a un tribunal eclesiástico los
obispos deben anunciar el martes las
medidas disciplinarias que pondrán en
marcha para acabar con la impunidad en
la iglesia
en antigua Guatemala ciudad patrimonio
de la humanidad por la UNESCO se lleva a
cabo un festival de flores que atrae a
más de 400.000 personas un homenaje a
una industria pujante que en esta
oportunidad le rinde homenaje a las
perpetuas rosas nuestros corresponsales
en la región Aurora Bayou y Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo nos trae en la historia
la víspera del festival de las Flores es
el momento para vestir esta ciudad de
Centroamérica Lupita Toledo es una de
las floristas más experimentadas por
haber sido la primera ganadora de este
evento que convoca a 2.000 artistas la
emoción de trabajar en las noches es
para que mañana amanezca que se inaugura
el festival
amanezca todo adornado y que todos
nuestros visitantes todas las personas
cuando Despierten verdad lo primero que
van a ver es la belleza de las flores en
las fachadas en las calles según la
asociación de exportadores de Guatemala
las flores aseguran el trabajo
permanente de 15.000 personas al año de
las cuales el 80% son mujeres en esta
edición Lupita escogió rendir un
homenaje a los vestidos icónicos de las
indígenas guatemaltecas realmente yo las
admiro a ellos las mujeres indígenas son
increíblemente creativas son una belleza
hacen bellezas con sus manos son
excelentes artesanas
llegó el día anhelado por los floristas
y con este el aroma de Las Rosas como
abejas con el polen más de 400.000
turistas se ven atraídos por los
arreglos florales el tema de esta
edición es el de las rosas perpetuas
bueno el Antiguo es conocida
románticamente como la ciudad de Las
perpetuas Rosas ha sido mucha
Inspiración de muchos poetas muchos
escritores incluso la historia del
Principito se cree que acá era el
asteroide b612 los artistas compiten por
ganarse el premio del arreglo floral más
original y pues los jueces lo que ven es
un poquito composición originalidad me
encanta por ejemplo esta esta Barbie que
tiene el traje típico de Guatemala y
tiene el café abrazado podría ser que
esto sea muy llamativo para los jueces a
la hora de calificar la industria de las
Flores deja una ganancia de 120 millones
de dólares
objetivo de orgullo para Guatemala
conocido como el país de la eterna
Primavera
queremos agradecer a la nueva librería
francesa por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para la grabación de este
programa ya ustedes también Muchas
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en trans
24 y trans 24 punto com